yes indeed after just a blistering
performance in this game carissa last
time you're on the show you said that
your friend said i roasted you i hope
that they
know what i said about you this game
because that was absolutely amazing
second time in the tournament that you
took down a multi-time champion by
picking off something on the b4 square
as well but the game itself just in
general you must be extremely proud to
have played it yeah i feel like it was
um
a very clean game and
i do feel a lot better having
having this game done because
like you said she's like a very strong
player so i was really nervous for this
one
but um like right after the opening i
got like a huge time advantage and i
just felt like my position was like much
easier to play
so i was already feeling pretty good at
that point you played some nice moves in
this game we liked uh bishop the bishop
b1 idea or she's down a rook and then
this queen to d4 queen to g4 maneuver
you must have felt great knowing your
pieces just look
completely dominant compared to hers
yeah i mean in this position her knights
are just so
misplaced it's like very hard for her to
do anything i can kind of slowly build
up on the king side
and
[Music]
yeah i mean
she can't really
i felt like she couldn't really do much
until until i like played some sort of
knight d4 and let her exchange off a
couple pieces
but like by then my king's side pawns
already rolling so
this plan of life for f4 rook d1 why did
you play rogue d1 tell us
oh i don't
actually know i was kind of trying to
play like natural moves very quickly
just to psych her out a little bit but
taking the rook off the c file open c
file is not as natural not so natural i
don't know i was like after i played
with d1 i think i played this move like
really quickly and then i was like hang
on i feel like the rick would be better
on on c1 but generally i just wanted to
keep like more pieces on the board so
make sense yeah
not giving any chance to trade and then
queen g3 finally getting in his knight
d4 idea and
now you just went straight for this plan
of f4 and f5 and it looks irresistible
yeah i mean
i feel like she
if she's like not already worse after f4
um
it's at least like very difficult for
her to play
so
yeah practical game and in the end you
found a way to win directly again this
nice move she took the pawn which is a
real mistake in that position although
it's very difficult for her and you are
now in clear first could you have
imagined it after you lost that bad game
a couple of games ago
i mean
it was like a really awful game right
but uh i was still half a point behind
first and everyone was like you still
have a point behind first stop being so
depressed and i was like you right guys
indeed well great comeback we'll let you
go get your rest enjoy this one
beautiful game should be in the best
game collection for sure with four
rounds to go still a lot of work to do
congrats thank you very good well done
chrissa we're not worthy we're not
worthy well done good luck in the rest
of the tournament
nice how was